today's Thursday August seventh and
you're watching gamespot news I'm Chris
water standing in for Jess McDonald I'm
wearing a light blue t shirt and I'm
only capable of making really basic
observations apparently these lights are
bright this rug is kind of crappy and
now I'm gonna read some news stories a
former Nintendo employee thinks the name
Wii U is abysmal and here I thought I
was the one making really basic
observations dan Adelman who left his
position as nintendo's head of digital
content and development last week after
nine years with the company said the Wii
U has a lot to offer with great games
you can't get anywhere else then went on
to lament that quote the value of the
gamepad hasn't been justified the name
Wii U is abysmal I think that cuts sales
in half right there is a terrible name
really the source for so much of the wii
u's troubles or is it because the games
really haven't been there until quite
recently let us know what you think in
the comments below two of the developers
of diablo 3 ultimate evil edition came
by the gamespot studios yesterday
answered a whole slew of questions about
the game and gave us the final word on
the resolution of the xbox one version
according to Tiffany wat an associate
producer at Blizzard both the
playstation 4 and xbox one will run the
ultimate evil edition in 1080p although
the xbox one will require a day-one
patch to boost it up from 900p both
games will run at 60 frames per second
we've got the whole QA up on gamespot so
if you want answers to questions like
will there be patched support how does
the stat ranges command work in the
compare item screen and monk changes
just go ahead and watch the whole thing
one of the showcase exclusives for the
Xbox one rise son of Rome will be coming
to PC later this year with support for
4k resolution Crytek director of
business development Carl Jones said
rise will be a quote benchmark pc
graphics showcase when it is released
this year and quote probably for a long
time in the future the pc version will
include every piece of add-on content
released on the xbox one to date
including the Legionnaires trust sword
that was initially released as part of
the game special edition no specific
release date yet we just know that it
will be released sometime this
Paul sorry it's just so we gave the game
a poor point 0 at four point oh it's not
good and finally the man the myth the
soft-spoken Canadian legend behind the
mass effect trilogy himself Casey Hudson
has announced his departure from bioware
calling it without a doubt the most
difficult decision of his career Hudson
will be leaving the company he worked
for for 16 years on games starting with
mdk2 and neverwinter nights all the way
up through kotor and mass effect Hudson
will take a much needed break before
deciding what to do next and says the
development on the new IP and Bioware's
edmonton studio the next Mass Effect
game and Dragon Age Inquisition is all
going smoothly we wish Casey all the
best in his new endeavor and will
remember fondly all the sassy sentient
and sniper faced robots he sent to kill
us throughout all his games share some
fond kotor Mass Effect memories in the
comments below and we'll see you
tomorrow